par ailleurs l'aide de québec aux
entreprises québécoises pour contrer la
pandémie est sous utilisé le programme
d'urgence aux pme est utilisé à 40 % de
sa capacité de 250 millions de dollars
au total à près de 3000 entreprises qui
ont eu recours à un prêt ou une garantie
de prêt en totale en moyenne à 35 mille
dollars et plus grandes entreprises qui
nécessite plus de liquidités peuvent se
tourner vers un autre programme qui lui
aussi shoes utiliser le ministre de
l'économie pierre 7-eleven dit miser sur
les mesures de tahoua pour combler les
besoins des entreprises
justement on retrouve le ministre
fatigué bonne ministre de l'économie de
l'innovation du québec nous sommes
monsieur fait tribune bonsoir de 27
heures de haut les statistiques nous
donne l'impression que le plan daide
pour les entreprises répond peut-être
pas aux besoins des entrepreneurs
pourquoi je sais pas si tu la sors je
vais m'assurer faire tourner juste titre
et après 3000 entreprises sur profiter
du programme avec les fonds locaux
d'investissement pourrait monter à près
de 100 millions $ pour l'instant alors
que le programme géré par investissement
québec s'adresse aux plus grandes
entreprises
après 700 qui ont aussi le programme
pour des montants pas de 1.5 milliard je
pense que faut reconnaître que d'une
part les banques et gestions financières
on joue un rôle important pour aider
nous entreprises du québec et que
d'autres entreprises non tu n'as pas
besoin de liquidités alors je pense que
je vais apprécier mettant une chose de
négatif
nous avons mis 2.5 milliards
disponibilité 1.5 utilisé présentement
les assauts milliards seul chef 2.5
milliards qui avait été établi
honnêtement une estimation nous avions
été fondée sur aucun tournage parce que
le programme d'abord disponible et au
besoin il sera utilisé donc c'est pas de
dessin 20 pour vous et là vous vous
semblez comptait beaucoup plus sur le
gouvernement fédéral c'est que les
programmes fédéraux sont plus populaires
c'est ça non je pense que les
l'important c'est que le québec nous
devons être un complément avec le
fédéral général de programmes pour
genève met le filet social ne la pcu on
à la subvention salariale du très bon
programme
nous aidons nous entreprises alors les
entreprises aux accessoires au programme
du pacte
paris estimant qu'avec ou soit le
programme des fonds locaux
d'investissement alors c'est disponible
ces gens n'ont pas besoin ils prendront
pas les gens vont emprunter
moi je pense qu'il faut attendre mais on
a encore une période quand même assez
longtemps à vannes ou 18 mois pendant
qu'on reprenne attend qu'on reprenne
plus tôt le niveau de notre pays big
nous avions est ce que c'est vraiment
parce que les entreprises n'ont pas
besoin monsieur fait débat nous parce
que ce qui est offert ce sont des prêts
des garanties prêts veulent pas
nécessairement s'endetter davantage est
ce que ce sera possible de modifier les
programmes le fond d'un instant j'ai
toujours dit que on avec dans les connu
nous ne connaissons pas le nouveau monde
dans lequel nous allons opérer
alors c'est important comme gouvernement
que nous puissions supporter les
infrastructures dont on a fait des prêts
de liquidités
il ya beaucoup de liquidités disponibles
on a créé un fonds de la banque
nationale on accueillait des fondus
effet l'idée est celle s il ya beaucoup
d'argent disponible vous avez pendant
noter que ml coût des emprunts sont bons
est ce que les entreprises doivent
s'endetter en permanence il faut faire
attention vous avez raison mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la le focus numéro un
pour le gouvernement c'est s'assurer que
nous entreprises puissent continuer à
survivre par des prêts on veillait comme
ans plus tard on pourra juste et au
besoin à ce moment ici j'étais
l'économie va mal il ya quand même il va
te ca de 104 emplois de moins que nous
avions au mode de ces prix à la pompe
est monté à 8 cents par action je vous
emmène ailleurs fait en quelque sorte
lancé ce matin
l'analyse des crédits budgétaires vous
avez dit que les données de la ramq us
est une mine d'or qu'on pourrait s'en
servir pour attirer les pharmaceutiques
est ce que vous avez l'intention de
vendre nos dossiers médicaux
non je pense que le contexte de sauce et
que c'est reconnu mondialement que le
les données scientifiques ont fait d'eux
des scientifiques sont requises pour
améliorer nos thérapies pour la médecine
personnalisée
nous avons au québec des hôpitaux
universitaires de premier ordre en
pensant à rosemont de nairobi ville
on a beaucoup de chercheurs qui veulent
profiter des données scientifiques pour
améliorer nos thérapies les des gens
sortis ciel nous avons fait
au québec nous sommes les champions du
monde les données et les algorithmes
qu'on peut faire son c'est incroyable ce
qu'on va pouvoir faire avec soin
de toute évidence il faut travailler
avec l'accès aux données il faut
protéger des personnalités au plus vite
donc ma collègue sonia lebel est
responsable pour revoir tout le côté
données personnelles mais un jour quand
on va pouvoir d'user donné ça va
profiter à toute la société
donc un jour écrit plein de projets en
cours là vous n'êtes pas en négociation
pour attirer des pharmaceutiques pour se
servir de la base navale qui n'ont pas
ce que c'est pour de supposées être
sympa mais je peux vous dire par contre
que nous nous chercheurs et des gens
sortis ciel non médecins veulent tous
pouvoir accéder aux données parce que
ces données dans ces données
scientifiques qui ont une valeur
incroyable
on pense au futur on pense la thérapie
moderne il faut se savait des données
mais la bonne façon a dit il faut pour
sa part air des filtres important pour
protéger les données personnelles
montrent un doute mais pourquoi vous
pouvez pas faire ça sans le consentement
des québécois comprenez que ça choque un
peu l'idée qu'on vende les données des
dossiers médicaux pour les profits qu
international vu comme ça vous avez
raison d'un côté je pense que tous les
gens tous les citoyens veulent voir deux
adultes compact le cancer devrait
disparaître jouera quand on pense aux
génomes toutes les zones éligibles au
mic
je pense qu'avec les données
scientifiques que nous avons on peut
améliorer de façon substantielle les les
moyens de guérir les maladies rares
maladies
tous les ans tous les citoyens veulent
voir de la bonne façon c'est pas devant
des données c'est utiliser données pour
que on est des médicaments ou des
thérapies soit adaptée aux besoins de
chaud on est on est privilégié d'avoir
au québec via le milieu il va d'où des
chercheurs scientifiques qui peuvent
nous aider à améliorer le sort de tous
les québécois
vous avez lancé une idée je suis
certaine ça va susciterait beaucoup de
réactions merci d'avoir été là c'est
beaucoup